[Música]
essa minha história começa com o cavalo
marinho
há muitos anos aqui há 11 anos mais
exatamente eu passando os olhos foi uma
conquista científica conta também com
uma enfim uma base de divulgação é por
seu mundo uma imagem de um cavalo
marinho que comia partículas de plástico
antigas plástico é e na altura fiquei
muito surpreendido e enfim eu tenho um
pouco incrédula como é que é possível
que tal coisa acontecesse
o facto é que percebi que realmente há
várias razões para que isso aconteça é e
que o problema é de facto muito complexo
e do sul são muito ficava é e que
rapidamente conquistou minha atenção e e
desde então tem vindo a estudar esta
esta questão é e ao mesmo tempo que o
estudo do ponto de vista científico tem
também tentado de alguma maneira é ver
promover um pouco essa mudança que é tão
necessária é e que todos nós temos que
fazer mais tarde ou mais cedo só para
contextualizar um pouco eu vou falar que
o lixo marinho tanto se encontra em todo
logo a maioria composto por plástico
portanto quando falamos do lixo marinho
é do poste que estamos a falar na
realidade eu está a superfície está no
fundo do oceano está nas praias sua
fração mais visível até aquela que
flutua em apenas uma pequeníssima fração
do tudo aquilo que se encontra já no
fundo dos oceanos dado que há décadas
que enfim é deitar é de uma forma
incorreta lixo os oceanos e portanto eu
tenho é enfim está distribuída em todo o
lado infantil é um problema global como
enfim como hoje em dia é mais ou menos
do conhecimento público os seus impactos
são também bastante importantes não só
do ponto de vista teste estética de
risco para os utilizadores mas também
impacto econômico na pesca nos
transportes marítimos e também
ecológicos nos ecossistemas e muito
provavelmente é certamente se estender
ao homem embora de uma forma ainda
talvez um pouco de conhecida neste
momento é incerta
- que é tudo isto impõe uma mudança uma
mudança que tem que ser é o mais urgente
possível se pensar em que em cada minuto
que passa há um caminhão de plástico que
é despejada no oceano é tanto são
números globais são estimativas
de facto a ansiedade isso acontece é que
o lixo e chega aos 100 anos não é
compatível com o facto de estarmos ainda
espero fazer alguma coisa a pensar muito
porque vamos ver se temos ou não quer
mudar as nossas atitudes só temos temos
e não temos há muito tempo este plástico
quando chega aos 100 anos enfim
dependendo do tempo que está à
superfície importante que é sujeito à
ação dos raios solares acaba por se
fragmentar fica quebradiço e tanto deste
ano materiais são depois prontamente
comidos confundidos com o alimento por
muitos por muitos organismos marinhos e
tanto nos oceanos existem hoje poste
custos de todas as dimensões desde os
maiores objetos até as mais pequenas por
partículas muitas muitas aves marinhas
por exemplo o rendimento no mar tem
tenho visto as suas populações bastante
diminuída se é porque se alimentam de
posse por engano não fazem questão
alimento as crises nos ninhos com
plástico e portanto tudo isto se traduz
depois num problema imenso é que
adicionamos também depois partículas
mais pequenas ainda que que encontramos
nos pés por exemplo que os pais que nós
comemos ou nos bivalves nupcial por
exemplo é nas demais ruas tanto
virtualmente todos os animais dos
oceanos é tem à sua disposição com o
movimento é essas partículas
é claro que hoje em dia sabe-se já
bastante mais do que recebi há uns 10
anos atrás quando eu iniciei as taxas de
estudos e de facto é muita coisa tem
sido já feita e é com muita satisfação
evidentemente que as pessoas que eu vejo
as pessoas passarem também esta causa de
alguma maneira estarem a disponíveis
para mudar alguns dos seus
sabe de coisa que tem vindo a acontecer
é todos os fins-de-semana direito hoje
em dia quase são organizadas limpeza de
praia é por grupos filmagem dos
informais às suas envolvem são a praia
chegam depois com o com isca tiraram que
impediram de chegar ao mar e portanto é
uma causa que eu vejo que as pessoas
respondem é um problema fácil de
entender por outro lado não é não
precisamos perder muito tempo a explicar
que o lixo não está onde está não é
importante é tem surge também outras
medidas um pouco também por imposição da
da da união europeia é uma estratégia
para os plásticos têm tudo isto vai dar
uma maneira também é revolucionário ao
encontro já do que é do que se sentia
enfim que principalmente diria talvez
até r discussão desloca muito
vocacionadas para o trabalho no terreno
e que há muitos mas já vai fazendo as
suas ações no sentido de sensibilizar o
público e os diferentes setores da
sociedade por que não dizê lo é para
este problema é a própria indústria aqui
é hoje uma parte da função é promete
novas embalagens com design mais e mais
ecológico mais fácil de reciclar o
governo tomou várias medidas contra os
plásticos descartáveis entanto há um
movimento em torno deste deste problema
que aqui é um problema global
é este este movimento é congrega já
muita muita gente à sua volta vários
pequenos negócios também são montados em
torno em torno destas questões e
portanto é sempre que há um movimento só
estão interessadas em mudar é e portanto
em fazer aquilo que deve ser feito facto
é porque de facto é um problema de todos
nós é e portanto só através das ondas
vontades de todos nós também poderemos
de vida só ver e certamente que essa
combinação de várias vontades várias
medidas legislativas são é ter tudo isto
contribui facto para que é este problema
possa de alguma maneira ser minimizado
reduzido eo minava
no entanto nós continuamos a ir à praia
como sempre fomos noé e olhamos à nossa
à nossa volta e muitas vezes acabamos
por ficar um pouco desanimados com
algumas das coisas que vemos não é
porque o grafias recentes indicam que
apesar de toda essa movimentação apesar
de toda esta vontade de mudança do facto
é que continuamos a ter imagens como
essa que eu estou agora aqui estou a
mostrar e que vai colocar outras
questões que é de facto a a mudança
efetiva de comportamentos que tarda em
acontecer ou seja é o que eu tenho
reparado recentemente que é maior parte
das pessoas muito preocupadas com essa
questão do plástico e luis marín e mika
algumas delas já têm vindo a modificar
seus hábitos do facto participam agora
muito esse mais envolvem esse trazer
seus amigos e familiares é envolvem-se e
vem limpar as praias e e e fazem muito
vai e com muito contentamento mas depois
quando chegam a casa com sua digamos
consciência tranquila porque fizeram
vovô ação é na verdade continua a fazer
tudo exatamente como sempre fizeram
antes e portanto é mudança de
comportamentos não acontece não não
surge center minha mensagem é que é no
sentido de que temos que ter um
compromisso assumir um compromisso com
este problema é tentar facto mudar nosso
comportamento limpar as praias é uma
coisa só em tem tido muito bons
resultados mas não é suficiente não
chega é reciclar e também é muito bom e
deve ser muito incentivado ainda fica
muito pouco em portugal e no mundo
mas fax com a gente também é uma maneira
de nós dizemos a não faz mal eu consumir
esse plástico que eu vá para reciclar e
portanto também aqui uma parte que não
presta um bom serviço não é portanto
temos que deixar pensar nesta
conveniência não é tentar eliminá las às
nossas vidas o plástico tem sido
fantástico é um material fantástico
certamente continuará sendo para ter
múltiplas aplicações
mas aí muitos casos nós temos que tentar
fazer outras opções temos que nos
comprometer com isso temos que focar
temos que organizar o nosso tempo temos
que tentar de alguma maneira fazer
opções mais sustentáveis que já existem
é claro se elas não existissem é mais
difícil mas agora já existem começam a
acontecer muitas coisas podemos
certamente escolher comprar a fruta
avulsa em vez de comprar a fruta
embolada podemos comprar lojas que não
tem dois outros pacotes lá dentro
podemos não usar cotonetes plástico
existem outros nas prateleiras dos
supermercados integravam com facilidade
em cartão por exemplo linhas precisamos
realmente eu só queria ficar um pouco de
cartaz no fundo poucos de cartaz são um
dos grandes problemas que nós temos hoje
em dia e estão também dos itens que mais
aparecem nas praias é temos de facto
inverter esta situação e isso passa
muito pelo indivíduo não é portanto é o
indivíduo no fundo somos nós e todas as
instituições são indivíduos o fim ao
cabo
somos nós que temos o poder no fundo de
reverter essa situação através das
nossas atitudes e é a mensagem que
queria deixar aqui é precisamente essa
tema escrito facto e inverter as nossas
atitudes nosso tentar mudar o nosso
comportamento e fazer as opções
sustentáveis e e isto é de facto um
caminho muito ambicioso é que há uns
meses atrás havia uma fotografia é
assentos muito recentes de um cavalo
amorim do novo pra pegar com início da
história é este cavalo marinho agora não
comia partir deste plástico que este
cavalo marinho fazia estava enrolado no
macho de um cotonete e o atleta ainda
tem algodão e tudo portanto era cento é
de essa imagem quem viu essa imagem que
pessoas muitas vezes nem na internet e
nas redes sociais são um movimento um
modo divulga sal extraordinário e chegar
a muita muita gente esta fotografia é do
facto é feijão pensar pronto é a
primeira vez que o contacto com este
problema e fica realmente precisa com o
que estava a acontecer as coisas não
mudaram muito não é mudar um pouco e
agora esta nova fotografia num cavalo
marinho com o coton enrolado no cotonete
diz muito é do impacto que as nossas
atividades têm nos oceanos
nós temos que pensar melhor é giro de
uma forma mais sustentável e consumir
menos principalmente limpar é bom se
claro é bom mas consumir menos -
plásticos preferência e fazer menos lixo
será sempre é que o que nos poderá
salvar um pouco mais longe enfim em prol
de um mundo melhor que no fundo acho que
o pessoal quer que o que todos nós
cremos que um terceiro termos um mundo
melhor e é por isso que eu estou aqui
hoje é deixar esta mensagem e muito
obrigada
[Aplausos]